الجغرافيا عود الكبريت الذي اشعل الحرب في
اوكرانيا قبل عام لم يعد الصراع بين بلدين
بالنسبه الى كييف فانها تخوض حربا نيابه
عن اوروبا باكملها اما موسكو فترى انها
تقاتل النيتو على ارض اوكرانيا تتباين
ادوار المتصارعين وحلفائهم على رقعه
الشطرنج تلك ما بين داعم للحرب ومؤجج لها
ولاعب لدور الوسيط ومن اختار الحياد ادوار
تحددها المسافه مع موسكو او كييف
لربما يشعر الاتحاد الاوروبي بنوع من
الطمانينه بقدرته على كبح روسيا عن اي فعل
اخر يتعدى حدود اوكرانيا تتلاشى هذه
الطمانينه او تكاد لدى دول البلطيق الثلاث
لاتفيا
وهي الاقرب جغرافيا لروسيا فالدول الثلاث
كانت اول بلدان الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
التي حظيت بحق الاستقلال ابلارا انهياره
اوائل تسعينيات القرن الماضي يلقي التاريخ
بظلاله القاتمه في منطقه البلطيق واقصى
شرق اوروبا حيث بولندا ورومانيا فالخشيه
من مصير مشابه لما يحدث في اوكرانيا تتخذ
دول البلطيق وبولندا ورومانيا من عضويتها
في النيتو درعا يدرء عنها اي فعل عسكري
روسي فمنذ اليوم الاول للحرب تطالب بتعزيز
الوجود العسكري للنيتو على اراضيها واقامه
قواعد دائمه للحلف على حدود اوروبا
الشرقيه والشماليه مع روسيا وطوال شهور
الحرب تحولت
الى ممر ينهمر من خلاله الدعم العسكري
الغربي على كياب
فلاديمير بوتين وحليفه الاقرب الكسندر
لوكاشينكو لعل صورا كهذه تشي بالكثير عما
تعنيه بيلاروسيا لروسيا في حرب
جيوستراتيجيه بامتياز يرى الغرب بيلاروسيا
طرفا في الحرب وان لم تشارك فيها في ظروف
الحرب الراهنه يكفيل موسكو الا يتمكن احد
من اي واجهه لها ضربه في الظهر من الاراضي
البيلاروسيه في سبتمبر الماضي كانت سماء
خاركيف شاهدا على ما قيل انه دعم ايراني
لروسيا في الحرب في اوكرانيا ظل مستترا
الى حين اعلان الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط
طائره مسيره ايرانيه الصنع ليشتعل جدل
المسيرات الايرانيه المحلقه في سماء المدن
الاوكرانيه بين طهران والغرب
وبينما اختارت دول مع اي الفريقين تصطف
اختارت تركيا وهي العضو في النيتو
والساعيه لعضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي ابقاء
الطرق مفتوحه الى الكرملين لا يخفي الجيش
الاوكراني الدوره الحاسمه لمسيره بيرقدار
التركيه في ميدان الحرب ضد روسيا والرئيس
التركي هو احد قاده العالم القلائل الذين
يتحدثون بانتظام مع بوتين وهو ما افضى الى
اتفاق تصدير 25 مليون طن من الحبوب
المكدسه في صوامع اوكرانيا عبر موانئها
على البحر الاسود توصف تركيا بالمكان
الامثل لاستضافه اي محادثات روسيه
اوكرانيه عندما يحين الوقت للحرب كي تضع
اوزارها وتصبح الكلمه الاولى للسياسه
ميقات يراه المسؤولون في الغرب بعيدا لكنه
ات لا محاله
[تصفيق]